sixteen-year-old nephron had to flee
from her violent Turkish husband now the
young woman and her baby are back in
safety in emergency housing with her
parents and siblings nephrons family
comes from Syria a family friend
Imam Abdul Rahim chalak is here
otherwise the shy frightened girl
wouldn't talk to us my husband threw me
and the baby out on the street my
father-in-law beat me and the child one
time he even held a pistol to my head
missins parents married her off for the
bride price before money to survive but
the husband just wanted a temporary
flame this is not an isolated case more
and more Turkish men are paying for a
second wife from Syria most don't want
it publicized this most of these men
don't want a civil ceremony just a
religious one that makes it easier for
them to get rid of the women again and
many say they want to Syrian as a second
wife but only secretly always ask them
aren't Syrian women worth just as much
as Turkish women don't they have the
same rights sweetie I didn't call them
let it up because that day I did it
Gaziantep the city of a million and a
half is just a hundred kilometers from
the Syrian border it has taken in more
than 250,000 refugees from the fighting
in Syria three-quarters of them are
women and children
most of the women are widows their
husbands died in the Civil War in their
despair they are easy prey
Turkish men think these women can be had
cheap as a wife or a second wife some of
them couldn't get to know a woman in a
normal way they're either too ill or too
old
a Syrian wife costs half as much as a
Turkish one about 1,500 euros for a
refugee family who has nothing that's a
lot of money word has spread that they
are being exploited I still wouldn't
give up my daughter they are merely
abused for two or three months and then
sent back again polygamy is illegal in
Turkey but in the conservative
patriarchal Anatolia region many men
don't care about that law the trade in
women is now a flourishing business
along the Syrian border just outside the
refugee camps marriage brokers display
photos of women and girls they make a
commission if a deal is made we drive to
one of the last still open border
crossing points between Turkey and Syria
beside it is a refugee camp that has
several thousand people were not allowed
to film inside but street vendors in
front of the camp confirm the
trafficking in women is routine here
interested men are constantly coming and
asking around people from the camp help
them find a girl or women middlemen come
on other days it's estimated that
thousands of Syrian women have already
been sold as wives the Turkish
authorities feel no responsibility only
a few Imams object to the practice in
their sermons Imam gellick reproaches
his colleagues he says that when they
perform these dubious marriages they
become accomplices
because Luana myself Yankee district
marriages performed by an imam have no
legal standing if no civil ceremony is
carried out
no Imam should give his blessing to such
temporary marriages that lasts only a
few months imam chalak provides former
bought wives like Nessman and their
families with the absolute necessities
after expulsion or flight from their
home country now these women face rape
and discrimination in an unfamiliar land
meirin says she feels like an inferior
being a few days ago my husband called
up and said he'll now marry a proper
woman a Turkish woman men are constantly
approaching me but I won't be giving up
any of my girls again
but miss rim is not so sure of that she
wants to watch out for her 13 year old
sister men have already offered a bride
price for her to